>> With respect to the economic crisis and
the financial crisis of the
past couple of years, we're concentrating
at Davos and working with the
other G-20 countries in making sure that we
are in agreement on
continuing stimulus for next year, because
the economic recovery is
modest and there's a lack of evidence of firm
private sector demand
return ing.
So we need to continue the public sector demand
which is through the
stimulus program, not only in Canada but in
the other G-20 countries.
We're also looking at avoiding this kind of
crisis in the future or
minimizing the impact of it by a mutual assessment
process which is
designed to be done by the International Monetary
Fund.
And we've had discussions here today about
the best design of that.
We'll follow up those discussion with discussions
in [INAUDIBLE]. The
G7 Ministers and bank governors from the G7
countries next weekend.
And then at the G-20 meetings at Cinema Stoka
and Toronto in June this
year.
So we have a lot of work to do on the financial
regulation side and the
reform of financial institutions in the G-20
which is now the premiere
forum for financial economic discussions in
the world.
Lots of work to do to get ready for the meeting
in June in Toronto.